der rheinland pfälzische
landtagspräsident hendrik hering sagt
dass die erinnerung an den holocaust
teil der deutschen identität sein da fdp
politiker alexander gauland bezeichnet
dagegen die ns zeit bekanntlich als
vogelschuss in der deutschen geschichte
und eine umfrage vor gut einem jahr
ergab dass mehr als ein viertel der
deutschen meint wir sollten einen
schlussstrich unter die beschäftigung
mit dem holocaust ziehen zwei drittel
meinen dass nicht wie soll man also
richtig gedenken ist es zu viel zu wenig
der zu flammen immer wieder hitzige
diskussionen auf nicht nur am
holocaust-gedenktag und um die zahlen
dazu und noch ein paar andere fakten
geht's jetzt
[Musik]
starten wir mit einer kurzen definition
in deutschland werden für die verbrechen
der nationalsozialisten und die
systematische vernichtung von mehr als
sechs millionen menschen verschiedene
begriffe verwendet der häufigste begriff
ist der den wir auch hier im video
verwenden nämlich holocaust genauso
üblich sind aber auch völkermord genozid
oder shoah viele denken bei diesen
begriffen vor allem an die vernichtung
der juden sie sind tatsächlich die
weitaus größte opfergruppe es waren aber
noch viele andere bevölkerungsgruppen
der verfolgung durch die
nationalsozialisten ausgesetzt zum
beispiel auch sind die roma kranke
schwache oder menschen mit behinderung
homosexuelle und menschen polnischer
beziehungsweise osteuropäischer herkunft
außerdem wurden oftmals sozialisten oder
kommunisten künstler schriftsteller und
gläubige verfolgt menschen konnten also
aus den unterschiedlichsten gründen zu
opfern nationalsozialistischer
verbrechen werden mehr dazu findet ihr
auch in diesem video hier dass wir oben
auf den verlinkten da könnt ihr das
nochmal ein bisschen genauer anschauen
aber wie sollen wir jetzt speziell in
deutschland mit diesem dunkelsten
kapitel unserer geschichte ist der
frühere bundeskanzler helmut kohl einmal
gesagt hat wie sollen wir mit diesem
kapitel umgehen eine spannende umfrage
dazu gibt es von der forschungsgruppe
wahlen die ergebnisse wurden ende 2020
veröffentlicht unter anderem auf die
frage sollten die deutschen einen
schlussstrich unter die beschäftigung
mit dem nationalsozialismus ziehen oder
sollten sie das nicht in den kommentaren
könnt ihr gerne schreiben was ihr dazu
denkt bei der umfrage war es so dass
mehr als jeder vierte für den
schlussstrich war 67 prozent waren
dagegen ist dass man einen genaueren
blick darauf werfen wer einen
schlussstrich ziehen möchte keine sorge
natürlich geht es nicht um die namen die
umfragen sind natürlich anonymisiert
aber wenn wir uns mal annähern wollen
sind es anteilig etwas mehr frauen als
männer eher menschen aus kleineren orten
also aus großen städten er aus dem
westen das aus dem osten er mit
niedriger schulbildung als mit
akademischem abschluss und vor allem er
menschen die selbst von sich sagen dass
sie sich nicht so gut mit der geschichte
der judenvernichtung auskennen gerade
letzteres ist wahrscheinlich nicht ganz
überraschend muss man hinzufügen bei den
altersgruppen ist es übrigens so dass
wir kein einheitliches muster finden
auch wenn prozentual wesentlich mehr
menschen ab 70 eine schlussstrich ziehen
wollen als die jüngste altersgruppe bis
29 jahre der jüngeren generation scheint
also die erinnerung an den holocaust
weiterhin wichtig und was ist mit den
unterschiedlichen altersgruppen ist es
eine generationenfrage wir haben um die
80 prozent
die sagen bei den unter 40 jährigen mit
sollen kein schlussstrich ziehen und in
der gesamtheit sind es 67 prozent also
das heißt es gibt eine kleine tendenz
dass ihr jüngere befragte dieses
wachhalten der erinnerungen stärker
betonen als ältere aber es ist keine
sehr große distanz die hier zwischen den
altersgruppen herrscht die
repräsentative telefonumfrage gehört
übrigens zu einer spannenden zdfinfo
dokumentation die deutschen unter
holocaust schluss mit schlussstrich
schaute auch gerne mal rein das lohnt
sich auf jeden fall verlinken wir unten
in der infobox seit 1996 gibt es in
deutschland einen festen gesetzlich
verankerten gedenkt tag den tag des
gedenkens an die opfer des
nationalsozialismus jedes jahr am 27
januar finden gedenkfeiern statt es wird
eine gedenkstunde dem deutschen
bundestag abgehalten der bundespräsident
hält eine ansprache und öffentliche
gebäude sind angehalten trauerbeflaggung
zu hessen seit 2005 ist dieser tag
übrigens auch international die
vereinten nationen haben den tag zum
internationalen tag des gedenkens an die
opfer des holocaust erklärt ziel ist es
natürlich der opfer zu gedenken
gleichzeitig soll der tag aber auch für
eine aktuelle auseinandersetzung mit
verfolgungen und mit diskriminierung
sensibilisieren und es geht auch immer
wieder um die frage wie sich gedenken
und erinnern mit der zeit wandeln und
vielleicht anpassen müssen muss sich der
geschichtsunterricht verändern welche
rolle spielen die sozialen medien in
zukunft bei der erinnerung und was ist
im umgang mit der vergangenheit
angemessen was nicht ist 111 ii vom
besuch des ehemaligen
konzentrationslagers in auschwitz zum
beispiel okay von besuchern die auf
gleisen dort passieren ist die
gedenkstätte zum beispiel offensichtlich
wenig begeistert das hört man immer
wieder ist auch verständlich wenn man
sich die frage stellt ob unser umgang
heute mit diesem kapitel deutscher
geschichte richtig oder unzureichend
oder übertrieben ist dann sollte man
auch einen besonderen blick darauf
werfen wie viel die bevölkerung
überhaupt weiß oder zumindest zu wissen
glaubt und auch da kann uns die umfrage
der forschungsgruppe wahlen weiterhelfen
vielleicht eine der ersten fragen zieht
dabei auf den begriff ab dabei konnten
77 prozent der befragten etwas mit dem
wort holocaust anfangen also die mit
völkermord oder judenvernichtung in
verbindung bringen die anderen 23
prozent also immerhin fast ein viertel
konnten oder wollten keine oder keine
korrekte angabe dazu machen das wort
holocaust stammt übrigens ursprünglich
aus dem griechischen und bedeutet soviel
wie vollständig verbrannt eine andere
frage betrifft die opfer die nicht
jüdisch war um mich eigentlich schon
erzählt hatte dass es neben juden auch
noch andere verfolgte minderheiten gab
48 prozent haben sinti und roma als
weitere opfer der verbrechen genannt 29
prozent gaben an dass auch homosexuelle
verfolgt wurden das auch osteuropäische
menschen oder regimekritische künstler
ziel des nationalsozialistischen terrors
werden konnten das sagt nur noch fünf
prozent der befragten und wo wir gerade
beim wissen sind auch interessant ist
die frage welche bedeutung das datum des
gedenktages hat also warum ausgerechnet
der 27 januar zum tag des gedenkens
erklärt wurde wer von euch weiß etwas an
diesem tag gewesen ist wenn ihr es nicht
will ist überhaupt kein problem damit
würdet ihr der mehrheit angehören nur 20
prozent der befragten haben beantwortet
das an diesem tag 1945 das
vernichtungslager auschwitz durch die
rote armee das sowjetische militär
befreit wurde das konzentrationslager
auschwitz beziehungsweise das
vernichtungslager auschwitz birkenau war
zwar nicht das letzte lager das von den
alliierten befreit wurde dafür aber das
größte mehr als eine million menschen
wurden zwischen 1941 und 1945 hier
ermordet wenn ihr darüber noch mehr
erfahren möchte dann kann ich euch
dieses video hier empfehlen über das
vernichtungslager da gibt es sogar ein 3
d modell dass diese schrecklichen
dimensionen vermittelt klar jetzt könnte
man natürlich sagen so ein einzelnes
datum das muss man doch nicht wissen und
klar zugegeben es ist wirklich nicht so
schlimm wenn man nicht auf anhieb weiß
was am 27 januar 1945 passiert ist aber
es zeigt eben doch einmal mehr dass
immer noch einige wissenslücken
existieren ein ganz zentraler
bestandteil des gedenkens ist ja aus der
geschichte für die gegenwart zu lernen
auf die frage ob und wie stark hat die
semitismus heute in deutschland
ausgeprägt sei antworteten 2020 78 also
mehr als drei viertel dass es keine oder
keine große judenfeindlichkeit gebe
gleichzeitig registrierte die polizei
2020 bundesweit mehr als 2400
antisemitische straftaten
dabei muss man sagen dass das
bewusstsein für antisemitismus in der
langzeitbetrachtung auch stark schwankt
2009 10 waren es 55 prozent die angaben
dass es keine oder keine große
judenfeindlichkeit in deutschland gebe
2018 62 und 2010 88 prozent wären einen
erhebungen zu dieser frage immer eine
mehrheit der deutschen die davon ausgeht
dass es bei uns keine oder keine große
judenfeindlichkeit gibt das generell zu
trend aber
diese mehrheit ist mal mehr oder mal
weniger ausgeprägt und diese
schwankungen die sie angesprochen haben
die stehen schon in einem zusammenhang
mit aktuellen ereignissen weil natürlich
wenn es übergriffe gibt antisemitischer
art wird darüber berichtet sind ist es
in den medien und dann ist es auch mehr
im bewusstsein und das
problembewusstsein diese thematik ist
daneben auch ein größeres ja man sieht
also die frage ob wir in deutschland
richtig mit der erinnerung des
nationalsozialismus umgehen oder
vielleicht doch eher damit übertreiben
oder zu wenig machen ist gar nicht so
einfach zu beantworten
der umgang mit der vergangenheit wird
uns wohl auch in der zukunft
beschäftigen ganz platt gesagt es geht
darum wie deutschland allgemein mit
seiner umgehen will und soll aber auch
wie jeder einzelne damit umgeht meine
persönliche meinung dazu ist ganz klar
wir sind nicht verantwortlich für das
was passiert ist aber wir sind
verantwortlich dafür dass es nicht noch
einmal passiert und das gilt nicht nur
für juden verfolgung sondern auch für
rassismus allgemein für diskriminierung
und alles was damit zusammenhängt und
ich frage euch wie steht ihr denn dazu
findet ihr es reicht langsam mit der
erinnerung oder findet ihr vielleicht
das viel zu wenig aufarbeitung passiert
sollte sich eurer meinung nach irgendwas
ändern schreibt gerne unten in die
kommentare lasst uns diskutieren aber
bitte gerade bei diesem thema bleibt
sachlich bleibt fair bleibt sensibel
dann komme ich dafür ihr leben hier
findet ihr noch ein video zu unserer
drei hier politbarometer to go zum thema
impfpflicht wer ist dafür wer dagegen
und noch darunter ein video mit einer
doku schluss mit dem schlussstrich ich
habe es vorhin schon mal kurz erwähnt
auch da gerne mal danke fürs zuschauen
und bis zum nächsten mal